votre histoire avec l'alcool a démarré
il ya longtemps au début c'était c'était
c'était pourquoi un parti méditer moi ça
vous l'êtes moins timide j'étais
extrêmement team et de petites et puis
quand j'ai commencé à faire les marchés
à l'île de ré le matin avec les primeurs
le petit coup de vin blanc et j'ai vu
que tout d'un coup ça me désigne l'ubaye
sa enlevé matthew est dit et ça a
commencé comme ça et ensuite ben ouais
c'est donc au départ vous ai dit ça ça
me fait du bien je me sens mieux je vois
là absolue mais c'est une catastrophe
parce que l'alcool on en trouve partout
c'est ce que je disais à laurent avec
lakovic 19 alors là les hp s'est plaint
non il ya carrément la queue pour
pouvoir y entrer et c'est très difficile
moi il m'a fallu trois fois pour m'en
sortir mas qui m'a sauvé c'est la foi et
l'amour d'accord alors mais c'est vrai
que c'est une maladie
prend en fait sa petite fille vous allez
dire de toute façon tu avais bien dit
monsieur bon moment c'est à dire que
vous buviez combien combien par un par
jour un moment ah bah moi je me
réveillais le matin c'était le rhum à
tige el hawa directs et indirects ah oui
direct l'antigel way et après dans la
journée ça continue et ça continuait
dans la journée
en fait un bond vous n'étiez jamais dans
votre état normal à 6-6 et nos machines
chez bretonne quand même donc je tiens
bien c'est ça ouais je tenais bien je
tenais bien mais mais je suis fier
d'avoir écrit ce vous 15 kg en 2009
j'avais autour d'errance comment se
sortir de la drogue et changer les
hôpitaux psychiatriques et j'étais
content parce que de mon vivant j'étais
la première à avoir écrit son livre sa
bio tout seul j'avais vendu 80 milles
donc c'est vrai que maintenant je suis
devenu un exemple on me téléphone pour
me demander dans quelle clinique on peut
à lui pour décrocher mais si le rsa le
prévoit vous dites l'alcoolisme est un
suicide oui pourquoi ce que vous pouvez
expliquer ce qu'on sait si tous les
jours un petit peu sur moi et ça abîme
énormément chez les femmes si on faisait
du mal ah oui ça fait du bien ça fait du
mal puis ça abîme énormément moi je on a
parlé de sa façon à chaque fois que j'ai
une promo j'ai cette étiquette personnes
mais ça ça change énormément le visage
fin ça change de la morphologie total
house est très belle moi je sais pas ce
que je m'en suis sortie non il n'a
vraiment jolie vous bien sorti le jour
vous avez fait une pancréatite aiguë
savez que vous deviez tout arrêter le
docteur ses copines aux téléspectateurs
une pancréatite aiguë le toit grâce et
une blanche sur pas loin du foie est en
fait c'est comme si le cette glande
allait éclater c'est très très
schématique ce jeudi mais l'alcool
agressait les on peut mourir ouais là
vous avez eu peur jeune à votre âge il
est très peur j'ai arrêté à ce que le
médecin m'a dit madame g d'un vous
voulez continuer de vivre ou pas cher
oui j'ai je suis grand mère j'ai
j'ai mon fils j'ai des choses à faire et
ça va donner de déclic vraiment c'est
yahoo est complète mais derrière vous
avez pu arrêter complètement totalement
totalement à dire si le roi se meurt
j'ai eu autre chose j'ai l'amour qu'à
rentrer dans ma vie d'accord ça aide
énormément juste tout seul je pense que
je serai en corse aux médicaments la
vôtre à votre amoureux ah ben il le sait
il m'a dit
si c'est que je replonge il me dit ah
ouais ça donc c'est donc voilà donc on
va bouger papa papa